RETO MEIER: Today we're talking
about data catalog, the Anthos
sample deployment, and
Google Cloud talks.
I'm Reto Meier and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news
from the safety of our homes.
Google Cloud data catalog is
a metadata management service
that can help you manage all of
your data from one interface.
Accessible from within
the Google Cloud console,
data catalogs support both
technical and business
metadata, providing self-service
data discovery at scale.
We've just added our
Anthos sample deployment
to the Google Cloud Marketplace
so that you can explore
the platform on your own.
This test environment includes
a tutorial, several Anthos
components, and a
microservices application
running in a multicluster
Kubernetes environment.
For cloud-based
applications, more regions
means improvements in
both reliability and speed
for your users as high
performing applications
are better able to cater to
the needs of nearby users.
With the launch of our
newest region in Las Vegas,
we're bringing more flexibility
and capacity to the Western US
as well as three new zones
with low latency high bandwidth
networking.
Our data may be moving around
the world, but most of us
are still staying
safely at home.
Fortunately, our
developer relations team
is keeping the
conference spirit alive
with a new online series
of Google Cloud Talks.
Register online to add
sessions to your schedule
and get reminders
for upcoming events.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us to comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.